good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
monday jackie and i are so excited
to be back in studio spring has sprung
spring sprung while we were gone we are
so spring and so plenty today that's
always how it happens you take one foot
out of new york
oh this sprungs itself all over the
place spring but we're very coordinated
today i love your cardigan like i might
steal it
yeah no it's um just something i bought
you know
shopping like i do like just the ladies
that i am literally so cute no it was
like one
i'm a very specific type of shopper like
i shop online i buy things in multiple
sizes i come
usually i hate it sometimes this was
something i've never done before like
walked into bloomingdale's picked it up
and bought it i didn't even try it on if
you're gonna shop in person that's
really the way to go and so that's how i
shop now like i
just buy i don't try on and i buy things
that i know are going to fit like
nothing too complex
because those fitting room situations
are just tragic and they're hurtful
no that's the thing it's like i have to
protect myself
and i think the best way of doing that
is never setting foot in a
like a department store fitting fitting
room ever again like i will go home try
it on in the comfort of my own home
with my peaceful home and my good
lighting and then i will return tomorrow
to return the items if that's necessary
right but it has to be really bad for me
to return it like even if it looks a
little weird on me i'm like i'll wear it
no because honestly so much of the
clothing that i buy is for the show
and like i can wear certain things
sitting like this that i couldn't wear
out and about like out to dinner
100 like this outfit today does not look
good standing up same but i think we'll
look good sitting down because like it's
the midsection area
that gets hidden on this show which is
like so fabulous for us right so this is
but then we take the post show picture i
know
i need to address something because
la the last show that we did i wore that
big
pink leather jacket
you probably don't remember it and we
look at the photo the photo is a
disgrace
and someone sent me a screenshot of
myself in the
youtube stream and i thought that they
photoshopped it to make my shoulders
look really big
like funny and then i looked at the
youtube stream and that's actually what
it looks like i look like a clown
oh yeah and i just want to say the thing
is is that as bad
and i'm sorry no and it's fun you know i
actually got many compliments that day
about my outfit people really saying red
is my color
but about your outfit okay would i ever
wear this no and does it look
good no it doesn't look bad but i have
so much respect for that the
chance you take and i'm never gonna make
fun of someone's outfit when they're
just trying to take a chance you know
thank you if you just want to have a
good laugh go to the youtube stream that
day
claude i thought that they made my
shoulders really wide to be like that
linebacker vibe no it wasn't even that
it's like uh when kanye wore that
um oh yeah when tom brady at the games
they wear those like huge puffer coats
that's literally what it was so you just
want to apologize and i
i tried to correct myself today
as long as you're always trying to do
better like there's no problem with that
no truly truly um we hope you guys
enjoyed the podcast episodes last week i
really enjoyed
taking um some time away from the studio
even though we had
literally just gotten back but we're
back now for the foreseeable future
might need to pick up and go to puerto
rico at some point this week but we'll
see
you just you never know what could
happen and that's the thing with like
you know
i don't want to say post coven but like
we're in the transitional period out of
covid like
you truly never know when you're just
gonna have to like pick up and go to
puerto rico and like hit the casino
and i'm deciding you know i have no
plans to i was actually
maybe gonna go to puerto rico tomorrow
but i decided against it oh that's
hysterical um
we should coordinate dates because i do
have something coming up and that might
be a good time for you to go
but also like feel free to go anywhere
anytime just bring your podcast mic
that's
all we ask of course and i actually love
um
like wait i know you don't love waking
up and like podcasting and like in your
underwear but i
live for it that is my natural state and
you
you execute the best work when you're
like looking stunning beautiful stunning
and smart
i execute my best work when like my hair
is in a knot and like i haven't showered
in four days and you're like hungover
yeah because i just have like no [ __ ]
left to give and it gives me like this
new podcasting
like outlook if that makes sense it's so
interesting i'm the complete opposite
because as you know i need delineation
so important to delineate so important
um
i don't know if it's a story but they
freed the suez it's our number one story
because it is like the story of the
world
and every if you weren't talking about
the suez canal at your seder like what
were you talking about oh my god first
of all i have two things to tell you
what you know what i learned about my
in-laws
first of all we talked about the suez
like the whole time and like because we
talked about it on the toast like
i was kind of like like the smartest one
there yeah
did you talk about the dutch naval
expedition no
i talked about couches
but then i found out something about my
in-laws that is so
insane that i the second they said it
i'm like i have to share this on the
toast okay because we're always swapping
tv shows you know i told them to watch
um we talk about woody allen v farrow
like
we were just talking about tv shows what
we suggest to them i told them to watch
college admissions scandal
um and you know what show they've told
me they've been loving
they're like have you watched the new
lisa vanderbilt show
i'm like bruce ava are you really
watching that
they love it and i'm like do you know
how low the ratings were you were
literally like a one percent of the
people who watched it they love it
okay i know it was a huge problem that
is a problem i didn't get into it
because it was a holiday and i didn't
want to you know yeah
put a damper on it i mean but you also
could give it a chance like i'm
i've moved on from the least of
vanderpump drama so have i and for the
most part
clean slate and so i don't think i don't
see myself watching it i literally
haven't turned on my tv in days i've
been on
such a reading kick plus now i'm reading
the book for the redheads i just like
tv who have not turned my tv on once
this entire weekend read two books
on by the same author but like gave me
such different feelings from both of
them
um i read hopeless which you and i
talked about i don't know by colleen
hoover
you guys i don't know if i would
recommend it especially like
huge trigger warning around like child
abuse and rape
i don't know if i would recommend it it
was not my favorite
i i mean snitch recommended that book to
me it was the last recommendation i took
from her
okay i'm glad that it wasn't because
last night i would not go to bed until i
finished this book it ends with us also
by colleen hoover
five five you know i only give five so
like three books five five five i loved
it so much oh my god it was
so should i read it jackie well you know
colleen hoover like also writes like
erotica rarity
so there is like a good amount of
erotica but it's really like it's not at
all what you expect
is it teenagers no it's grown grown okay
well she
there's like flashbacks to something
that happened in her teenage years
that's kind
it was so sweet i loved it so much i
couldn't something about it i dreamt
about it i was thinking about it all
morning when i was getting ready
i loved it and i heard that's also one
of the books that got picked up to make
a movie but they say that about every
book i know so it's hard
to get your hopes up so try not to but
that is really good to know i finished
the other bowling girl i don't think i
had finished it on friday
i think you did oh maybe i think i had
like five percent left
it was amazing obviously i'm so excited
to watch the movie i'm going to space
them out a little bit
i loved the book so much and and now i'm
going to continue on my chair
you know down into the tudor era
but i had to start the redheads because
we're recording tomorrow
detransition maybe it's so good i'm 50
of the way through
i'm so curious to see what happens like
it's it's really interesting
so it's never too late to become a
redhead i'm just going to say that
that's crazy
i know we're always on the same page um
speaking of crazy i had the craziest
experience like this
morning that i just need to share
because like the city is getting so
small
oh no so zach and i came home from
vacation last week
and when we came out of the airport we
got into what we thought was our car
and then we're like bags are in like
we're in we're searching
we needed to give the address and he was
like ma'am this isn't arby's
he's like east hampton we're like oh no
oh so like him and zach like got mad at
each other
that he was mad at us for getting in the
wrong car zach was mad at him for like
not
checking not checking but it's like it's
both our faults whatever no it's
common archer was the one right behind
it so we get in the car and
they had like weird beef as everyone was
like unloading the luggage and i'm like
this is something that happens often
it's really not a big deal we pull
out of the airport we're driving down
the street and zach realizes he left his
laptop in the first car
i literally like turn around they were
just pulling out behind us
so i ran out of the car down the street
and i like knocked on the window i'm
like is there a laptop in the car
and the passenger who had gotten in
after us she was like a young girl she
was so sweet she like found the laptop
and gave it to me and the driver starts
yelling at me he's like
i should charge you i'm like for what i
was like don't be like that it was a
mistake on both
because i was still really the only
level headed one in the situation like
my adrenaline was pumping like crazy
running down the street to get this
laptop what did you run into the girl
no i got the laptop and he's like
yelling at me he should charge me but i
don't even know you
and if if it had if he had realized any
later like we would have never seen it
again
because i don't even know what company
his car was from like his name like
whatever
this morning my uber pulls up no
and it's him no it's him did he remember
you
i don't think so because i looked like a
beast at the airport and today i was
like
all done but literally the entire time
in the car i was like trying to figure
out
could it be that's such a coincidence
but it was the same car the interior was
the same the same glass
he looked exactly the same it was
[ __ ] him oh my god that's a bug out
especially since we were
just talking about like getting in the
same car twice yeah no ever since
in the last like i guess a year the city
has just become so
small yeah i am always getting into the
same ubers like
i get the same drivers i'm like what's
good counts i literally
like never get the same drivers that's
so crazy isn't that
so crazy chilling yeah and like he had
no idea where we lived so
right it's not like he's not talking i
don't think i don't know if he knew
they're so identifiable i know but i was
like no makeup
sweats hair in a bun and like today i
was just like hair done
to you it's like a huge difference to
the average person it's like oh
she put her hair down you know it's like
how to montana
no literally like yeah like a transition
yeah
okay it's like clark kent like yeah
classes
right exactly like it's like hillary
definitely it's hillary tough with the
math like you look the same
yeah no it's literally brand new and
silhouette
like we ended on such bad terms it's not
even like something funny we could be
like were you the one because then you
would have been like get out
and charge me but you'll know if he
remembers you based on the rating he
gave you
oh i mean i was a model customer today
as i always am as i was
last i wasn't in this you were just
being reasonable i was i was so i'm
nothing if not reasonable so
that is just crazy so crazy that is a
wild story
gotta love new york so
that's where i'm at anything anything
else you want to share about your
weekend how was yours
we had seders this weekend yeah they
passed over everyone
the seder bops were sickening the seders
were lovely we had a great seder on
saturday night so nice to be with the
family so nice to sing the songs of our
people no it literally the seder our
seder in particular has so much ruach
so much energy spirit wind and that's
what ruach actually means rock
translates to wind
but it really means like experience like
energy
and then last night i went to ben's
parents you held a
small seder without me yeah no your your
absence was felt but it was a lovely
evening and
theo's absence was felt magnolia and
bruno were in heaven you know of all the
jewish holidays i really
don't mind passover aside from the whole
bread thing because that's
actually always harder than i remember
the actual festivities the seders i love
yeah no i never like think about
passover that much and then when we're
in it i'm like i love this
yeah and like passover gets a bad rap
because you have to do the seder before
the meal so
you think it's so much longer than it is
but like once you get older you realize
it's actually not that long
yeah but also like some people go for
like four hours i don't know but we
read every word in the book no but we
also
don't pick up afterwards oh right that's
what after shulhan arrest right
we miss hagad yeah well we just had got
last night
and um anime uh
[Music]
i forgot like that one brings me back to
like my school you know fifth grade
you know who would crush hagaria theo
mason ramsay because it's like a yoda
yeah
that's actually a really good call you
know he also just joined tick tock i saw
he posted a video and he went on a
podcast that
wasn't ours right i hate to see it it's
actually like
so disrespectful i know but you know
what maybe getting old oh so you know
what um
i was gonna say maybe when things like
start to go back to normal and celebs
come back to new york for
press that maybe he'll come on the show
but i feel like that's starting to
happen now
and addison wright kicked it off yeah
but i also think
people are never going to be going on
like as many press tours
as they once were because you can really
do everything from home yes for sure but
like
addison ray's recent press tour in new
york like was so buzzy
she's so and that and that buzz you
can't get from home
that's actually very very like her
walking in and out of the studio
boom boom like i just it made me miss
those days and i think they're on their
way back i actually think that's a good
call that was like a good kick off
yeah addison is everywhere oh my god and
she's
not only she everywhere but she is
everything of the sort
and i'm such like a fan and loving
watching her just like blossom
no i agree i'm loving watching her
ascend yeah when you look at old videos
of her it's like
she looks like a completely different
person like she really got like the
hollywood treatment
remember her long blonde hair yes but
she still
like she doesn't look like i can't i'm
not saying like plastic surgery yeah
yeah she just looks like
the you know it's like when you go
contestant on the bachelor
to the lead of the bachelorette exactly
exactly
so i'm just so proud of her and i don't
even know her same i was feeling very
proud of her as well her performance on
kimmel was sickening
it was fallon same thing so sick yeah it
was i mean those dance moves those pants
like she's just like
gorgeous we're foolishly mad to addison
ray yeah get well soon because you
sickened the performance down
totally um but we have a great show for
you guys i think we should get into
everything real housewives of atlanta
was on last night there's no bachelor on
tonight
let's celebrate i think maybe i'll go to
dinner to celebrate you should
i know i think maybe should plan
something like a little like small geno
oh i'm gonna be reading to celebrate
because i have to finish the book by
tomorrow
um so that means like all the redheads
are out like the redheads are out but
the redheads are in on tuesday we're
going to dinner after we record if you
want to join us i know just kind of like
my outfit so i'm like i need to
repurpose it wear it again tomorrow it's
not like you're really going to sit in
this all day
maybe i should right back to bed right
back i actually leave my pajamas
folded at the end of my bed so i can get
back in them after the toast i like i've
really gotten to like them into the most
unhealthy um routine this past year and
i don't know and i'm sure a lot of
people can relate to this like
i don't know how i'm gonna get out of it
like i can't believe i used to work like
full days like we used to be running
around town galavanting meetings
meetings meetings lunch
meetings meetings meetings now it's
literally like bed
a couple meetings on my phone that take
like so little effort
and i just don't know how to unlearn
that yeah
i think you've got to start slow so
maybe do
something today you know i really need
to like start
doing stuff come to dinner with us
tomorrow night okay
but it's like after a certain point oh
my god i forgot to tell you
so me and men are laying in bed last
night and we're like it is so bright in
here
and i'm like it's a full moon so like i
think that the moon must be like close
to our window like i'm literally making
stuff up because i don't even know why
it's so bright
and we open our curtains which we never
do in our bedroom like our curtains like
permanently stay closed because we're
always asleep and
there is like this new skyscraper
right next to my building that has a
light you know how a couple buildings
have like colorful lights that change
yeah like the
empire state yeah it's literally right
next to our
all night green to blue to red
to orange ben was letting it bother him
so much like it didn't bother me that
much
but like certain like when it turned
green it was so bright when it turned
red it was kind of like nice and moody i
felt like one of those tick tockers
yeah the red light but it's so it's like
the most bizarre
thing ever i swear the building was not
there that's crazy you're gonna have to
get blackouts a week ago i know
wow crazy right skyscrapers skyscrapers
um okay now now i think we can get into
the past five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
and would it be an episode of the
morning toast if it wasn't brought to
you by bruce
the simple answer is no bruce is the
most fabulous electric toothbrush
on the market that jack and i have both
been using for months
we have proven results it feels good
it's fun it's a gorgeous toothbrush and
it's super affordable
compared to other electric toothbrushes
on the market it comes with
you six unique modes to customize the
brushing experience
the battery life lasts four weeks it
comes with a magnetic charging stand
and a compact travel case but since the
battery can last up to four weeks
if you travel you more often than not do
not need to bring the charger which is
just like a fabulous thing
um they also offer a subscription
program so you can never forget to
change your brush head
again bruce will ship you new
replacement heads every six months so
you're never stuck using a worn down
brush head
brush is first of all so fabulous in its
design it's very sleek it's very elegant
you feel cool having it up
on your counter the replacement heads
keep you on track so you don't use
dirty moldy heads because that's how you
get bad breath
and it's so much better for the
environment the sleek design
has a modern aesthetically pleasing
design that comes in trend driven
seasonal colors
and it looks great on your bathroom
counter if you want to get 15 percent
off your brush toothbrush kit and refill
plan
use the promo code toast at bruce.com
that's 15
off using code toast at brush.com
promo code toast just don't be the last
toaster on earth without a brush
just trust us okay first story the big
story
of the day of the week she's free
traffic in the suez canal resumes after
the stranded
ship has re-floated and the de la sapps
family rejoices
yes this is a great day for the daylight
sepsis everywhere shipping traffic
through egypt suez canal resumed on
monday after a giant container ship
which had been blocking the busy
waterway for almost a week was refloated
the canal authority said the 400 meter
long ever given became
jammed diagonally across the southern
section of the canal in high winds early
last tuesday
halting traffic on the shortest shipping
route between europe and asia
so it's been about six days of halted
suez canal and now she's free and now
they're working to get all the ships
there was like
hundreds of ships waiting in line 369
vessels
oh my god yeah and the sad part was like
all the animals
on board like they didn't bring enough
food for the animals
but i did read that like egypt and the
other countries were sending
supplies and vets but it's still like a
goat it's not meant to be on a boat for
that long you know yeah yeah
goat boat no no no so i'm glad that this
has this was getting really stressful no
i know and it was like this thing we all
kind of
you know it's like everyone knows the
swez canal because it's like something
that you learn
in middle school that just like sticks
with you and so i feel like everyone's
like social studies course was like
coming back up yeah no i've never really
felt like anything i learned in social
studies was valuable
up until now yeah because i know that
the sweats canal is a major trading
route
major major trading route so i'm happy
for the routes
and i'm happy for the boats and i'm
happy for the canals yeah i'm really
happy that this has
has worked itself out me too but um it
was kind of fun to like all be talking
about the same thing for
one moment you know yeah and like for
like until it was
unstuck i was like is it ever going to
be unstuck what are they going to do no
but honestly people on tick tock were
coming up with their own ideas
for how to resolve the problem and i'm
not gonna lie like people had some bomb
ass ideas
like one of the best ones i saw was like
because it was stuck diagonally
so you chain the front of the boat and
you chain the back of the boat
on land to like huge semi trucks
and the trucks both drive in different
directions thus taking the diagonal boat
from this
to this do you know what i mean yes that
sounds like it would work but
could the trucks pull the weight of that
thing i don't know what you would use on
the
land to but also uh you don't have to
pull the full weight because it's in the
water so like
it would be less but still i thought
that was a good idea that's very
interesting i don't know that much about
like the issue itself and how it can
definitely be avoided in the future
but i just feel like the ships are too
damn big yeah now when i saw a picture
of the boat like with all those crates
and if you think if those crates are the
size of people's homes like
you know those shipping crates cargo
crates and they are piled the [ __ ] up on
this boat i'm like
for scale i couldn't even picture how
big it is longer than the empire state
building
right because those cargo traits insane
those cargo crates are huge like that's
the size of a regular boat like
it was just like to see them all stacked
up like really shook me yeah
and i just i don't know much about
shipping and this might be a
controversial thought
i just didn't think we need boats that
big but like maybe we do because there's
just so much cargo that needs to be
around
like sand carted yeah parted yeah
carried
yeah so i just i think this is a lesson
for the cargo industry
i think this they're definitely snatcher
learn your lesson
yeah and i hope that they they learn
something from this i don't know what
the lesson is but there is one
there is and that's the thing with any
situation any any challenge
in life there's always a lesson to be
learned and
i'm not sure what the one is here but
i'm sure we'll find out soon yeah no and
it's not a mistake if you learn
something from it
wow that's actually beautiful even
though this seems like a really big
mistake
huge like 169 ships i read a statistic
that every hour that shipping was halted
is a loss of 400 million dollars
and so it was for like the shipping jeff
bezos
yeah every hour that suez is blocked
cost the global economy
an estimated 400 million dollars oh that
includes us
oh no i'm not losing 400 million dollars
unacceptable not fixing the problem
fix the problem now and now it's fixed
well happy for everyone in the suez hope
this doesn't happen again
hopes nashua learned her lesson so
important
are you ready for our next story some
really happy news about one of our
favorite guys
who jason darullo is expecting his first
child with his girlfriend
jennifer i saw on tick-tock she's like
so stunning um i love this i'm so happy
for them on sunday she announced that
they are expecting their first child
together
couldn't be more excited for this new
chapter in our life he wrote on
instagram
so [ __ ] cute i think that one of the
great like com
not comebacks but rebrands of our
generation
was what jason derulo did for himself um
on tick tock it's so wildly he has 40
million followers that's like crazy
it's so impressive his songs like
perform so well
in the charts because like they just
blow up on tick tock savage love you
know
yeah so i'm like i'm
constantly impressed by his willingness
to just like
evolve yeah i feel that wait but
speaking of tick tock
has addison's song like been all over
like is there a dance
for it like there is but it's not like
viral it's just like it feels very like
promotional
oh really yes what's the clip like
what's the
when i send me to
and i said me too that's the part people
are using but like
i can't stress enough how it's like
really not being used that much okay
like there's really no like trend behind
it okay
but you know what song is going viral on
tick tock better than revenge by taylor
swift which it's just exciting
oh that's exciting it's not taylor's
version what are people doing with it
okay so
they're do they use a part of the song
the story starts when it was hot and it
was summer and
i had it all i had him right there where
i wanted him and they show a picture of
like them and their boyfriends
and then she came alone got him along
and then it's like a picture of the girl
with the girl best friend
and then she took him faster than you
could say sabotage then a picture of the
best friend and the boyfriend
so actually i'm gonna do the trend
because i went through something similar
um
i'll show you pictures later like you'll
see oh okay yeah i'm excited actually i
had the idea last night and i was so
tired i
really wanted to turn over and make the
tick tock but my book just like knocked
me out and i had to go to bed
was it about maverick no okay
but it's like along those lines like
it's a joke oh i'm so excited yeah
um i just don't want to say it's like i
want to get the tick tock up but also
now that i'm here follow me
talk i hit a hundred thousand followers
and i'm officially like not the biggest
loser on tick tock
you are oh my god that's i'm not honest
no you're not on tick tock so like
um i'm not in the game no but for the
longest time like i was the official
biggest loser on tick tock because i had
like no followers and i tried so hard
now i listen like the three digits 100k
yeah that's respectable
oh you have no idea like what a huge
relief it was for me
maybe i don't know i'd be like maybe you
need to rethink your tic toc strategy no
i definitely do
so let's rethink it i just like really
need to bring the energy that i bring
like on my instagram stories
to the tick tock community because i see
the most basic tick tocks that it's just
like
a thought and some no it's not even a
it's a sentence of a thought and then
like you put it with a green screen and
you like say your thought with also the
caption of the thought it's just like a
funny tweet
yeah no i have to figure it out but i'm
glad i made it this far thank you to
everyone who's been sticking with me
and i promise i will do better
okay i just think like maybe we could
strategize brainstorm i need to talk to
jason derulo and like whoever
um edits his tic tocs like is amazing
100 and honestly whoever edits his tick
tocks
pink hired because i just hired i just
followed pink on twitter on
tick tock and she like does literally
everything jason davilo does like with
the edits and stuff they obviously have
the same editor
um but she really only uses tick tock to
promote her new song with her daughter
which it's not that good
yeah no cover me in sunshine it just
actually
it actually really annoys me to song
yeah things when speaking
like it's the beginning the the
self-promotion has to be so subliminal
i know you need to do a hundred videos
for everyone that's your own song yeah
you know who does a good job is bb
rexella like she mostly just
participates in like tik tok culture and
the trends but then also promotes her
music every now and then she does not
perfect yeah she's actually i think a
lot of celebrities should look too
also charlie puth charlie puth actually
barely even promotes his work i don't
even know if he works but
he just like checker he just talks like
about how he has like 37 pianos in his
house like he actually does
and then he counted them for everyone
that's crazy john mayer just joined tick
tock and you know he's like this whole
like i'm old i don't know how to do it
but it's like funny and cute
and he's also promoting new music and
it's like john mayer could like
literally you know post blank videos
with no sound and i would think it's
genius so
um we love that for him yeah also this
trend of
everyone who's like upset about middle
parts and skinny jeans
yeah so that's like a particular side of
tick tock like i refuse to get on
because it's so [ __ ] stupid it's like
gen z versus millennials it's like
millennials wear skinny jeans and side
parts where
where gen z wears middle parts and like
dad jeans
so it's like if you like it's so stupid
i actually
stupid i can't even get into like that
whole like dialogue on
top because i refuse to even like
associate myself i just have one thing
to say
wear your hair how you want to wear it
and wear whatever jeans you like
and to be honest like maybe jeans are a
generational thing
but hair parts are not generational like
it's so
one size fits all like whatever works
for you like your face shape your hair
texture like
it has nothing to do with generational
it's so
just based on who you are yeah what are
you in your middle part right now it's
like skewed a little yeah so my part has
been creeping back towards the center
for a few years when i got a lob i it
was like a
side part lob and then as my hair grows
i like keep moving my part back
to the middle but it's always like a
little off center i love
a middle part so much like a straight
middle part
i'm i'm getting back there like but
maybe that's just me trying to conform
and be young
maybe maybe that's like i didn't even
realize i was doing it i refuse to
accept that a middle part is a young
person's thing i've been wearing a
middle part my whole life and like
i literally will never not wear a metal
part yeah it's a tail this time
it's just a personal choice like it's
not anything more deep than that
yeah i feel you well you ready for our
next story
yeah some happy couple news kourtney
kardashian and travis barker heat
up at the usc fight alongside megan fox
and machine gun kelly
this clip of like the celebrity
row you know like of the ufc fight where
they first show megan
and megan kelly machine omega machine
and then like they cut to courtney and
travis with the lollipops like
i die and i have to say i think
that this relationship with travis plus
her just now like pulling back a little
bit on kardashians
is gonna be the best rebrand that
kourtney kardashian
by the end of this year i'm telling you
mark my words will be like the best
kardashian
i'm telling you like i really feel the
tides starting to turn
you you'll feel that way about her i
think the culture like the society will
i think everyone will always have their
faves but i do think her her stock
is rising i think she's on like a huge
rebrand and she's gonna be like a
top-tier top three kardashian
it's just a lot of things are happening
also i'm gonna move to the bottom
i don't know i don't know if you saw but
um
they did that angie coming show for real
i didn't watch
um i didn't watch it either but i saw
clips going around where courtney
basically says she feels like she's
gotten an unfair edit on kardashians
um but andy was like but you you're a
producer that's what he said and she was
like yeah like i feel like i've made the
best
of like what we were given but she just
feels like
she it wasn't an accurate representation
of who she was so
i think maybe in this next year we'll
see the real kourtney kardashian
that's like i don't buy that for one
second she they have all these
long-winded conversations she talks
so slowly she does she's so many
confessional moments where she says
absolutely nothing like why don't you
pull from the confessional where you're
saying what you think represents who you
are yeah the thing is is that like i i
just generally don't like when people
are like i got a bad edit
especially when you own the show like no
no i can understand i got a bad edit and
then you hear years later like this is
what happened behind the scenes and and
then you see it for what it is but like
there's not like the kardashians choose
how they come off on the show
they have so many confessionals that
like they have so much time to fill
yeah you could fill it with the stuff
that you want us to see no but instead
we're getting fake story lines about mj
dating scott you know
no but like those courtney's
confessionals are so infuriating because
she doesn't say anything and she talks
so slowly yeah
if she had something she wanted us to
know like there's a time in place
whatever i was trying to say positive
things about courtney so
i think that this relationship is like
so good for her image
and like as well as so is the season so
is this season yeah so i just think it's
like actually like a really good
kind of month to be kourtney kardashian
is it just me or like did we say that
they were gonna go on a double date a
few weeks ago
i think we like compared their energy i
don't know if we ever
no we did because travis barker and
machine gun kelly like they wrote that
song together and they have like
we did we did yeah and then we said that
lala and randall will come soon but like
lala you know his new mom so they were
obviously busy oh yeah yeah and
i think that that's next and we said
what a six something no like just like
watching the four of them like interact
separately as couples like with the
lollipops like
was the bit like the serotonin boost of
the century like it was just like we're
used to seeing korean kardashian in like
very controlled environments like
the show which she controls her
instagram she's kind of seeing her like
in her natural state like it was like
kind of awkward those things always are
like
at basketball games they leave the
camera on the celebrities for like a
little too long
yeah um but like it was just very it was
so interesting
yeah i'm watching it right now like
they're just sucking on the lollipops
and she like turns her head away and
then this guy's like acting a fool in
the back
um and you know who else was at that ufc
game was matt james
oh with who with the guy who's dancing
in the back of courtney i think he was
there with matt but
they were sitting somewhere else oh
interesting that guy looks familiar
yeah so really i actually have like a
lot of questions about what's going on
with matt james
yeah he like remembers his instagram
put up like a tweet like march 24th what
day
yeah no it was like march 21st and it's
oh it's marshall 29 it's well past the
date
so what did we get i agree i have a lot
of questions so like now you're just
like showing up at celebrity events but
we have things that you
need to be clear about you're erasing
your whole instagram like a la colton
underwood
i don't know that that's the model so
but i think when anyone does that it's
so dramatic but like when a straight man
does it it's even more dramatic than
necessary
it's so dramatic like unless you're like
taylor swift
right now changing your whole brand vibe
and energy there's
no reason to delete all your a lot of
musicians delete all their social when
they have like a new era
which i still think is dramatic but okay
okay but it's dramatic but like do you
have a new era
right what's next right matt i don't
know we'll find out but speaking of
someone who's
always having a new era miley cyrus was
spotted
out and about with young blood getting
cozy
um miley and youngblood got cozy
thursday night
out at the rainbow bar grill on thursday
in l.a photos from the outing revealed
also it looked as though perhaps she had
been drinking again
after letting us know that she has not
been drinking right the articles that i
saw were like
more concerned it's like like miley's on
a bender
um and again there's literally no way to
know if that's true or not so
yeah but she had spoke she's spoken and
she spoke to rolling stone in the cover
story
about how she got sober when she was
halfway into 26 then
by 27 she was pretty much fully sober
then like a lot of people during the
pandemic i fell off it was really a
struggle mental health and anxiety and
all that she said to the publication
but then she was back on being sober for
five weeks
but then she was spotted taking shots
got it okay well i just like wish her
the best hopefully she knows
like she's in control of um
what do you think about a new
relationship uh who the hell is
youngblood
i mean all i know is young blood say you
wanna
[Music]
that's all i know also but he's like a
music producer he works with lady gaga
like i don't know what he looks like
he just reminds me of g-eazy by the way
because he dated halsey that's why and
this story
like not not that i know them personally
but it gives me
g-eazy demi lovato vibes like taking
advantage
of like a situation i've been meaning to
watch demi lovato's documentary because
it's literally
everywhere and demi lovato was on joe
rogan yes i know i saw a couple clips
um i'm just like it's like a lot of demi
like this last week and i'm just like
trying to pick and choose no and also
like a joe rogan episode like three
hours it's a lot of anyone
and so i don't know how i saw i think
i'll just watch a documentary
i saw a couple clips too and and i i
can't imagine that they were
like the best of the episode because i
found them to
like what she was saying like i feel
like
there are better things no one at some
point in like on a very small scale i
went through this with my book like
you're promoting a project like you're
keep hitting the same points
so it's like okay you can read all the
magazine interviews and watch all the
podcasts but at the end of the day she's
saying the same thing in every single
one but the thing about like going on
joe rogan at
three hours like you're you're going far
beyond what the usual talking points
were
and the clips that i saw felt like just
the talking points so that's why i was
like oh i don't know if i need to watch
it but then
he said it was a great interview and i
guess i'm sure it is
yeah by the way joe rogan likes in
september like officially went to
spotify exclusive and i feel like i
haven't heard that much
like like his podcast don't make as much
buzz anymore i just think that's
interesting
that is interesting but also i don't
think he's had like as
big of guests as he used to because of
the pandemic and he moved to
like austin yeah and i guess when he
does have someone that like you would
care about you hear about it
yeah no i just um i was like oh where is
show rogan where has he been and then i
remember he's on spotify he's on spotify
yeah exclusively so that's
that's what's up you know i'm i am gonna
watch demi's documentary because
what i've been hearing about it like it
does sound really good but it's a lot
it's just like a lot
of information you know from demi coming
out this month
yeah did you listen to her new song
i did yeah she's she's a great musician
yeah she's a great musician no one can
sing yes
about herself like quite like she can
um are you ready for our fifth and final
story only if it's a fit the final story
brought to you by honey
it is we all shop online and we've all
seen that promo code field
taunt us at checkout but thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past
honey is the free shopping tool that
scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one it finds to you
honey supports over 30 000 stores online
they range from sites that have tech and
gaming
to popular brands like food delivery i
mean i've used it on beauty on clothing
i'm pretty much anything you can think
of so many investments have been
made wiser by honey so many investments
here's how it works
you're shopping at one of your favorite
websites when you check out the
honey button drops down and all you have
to do is click apply coupons
if you wait a few seconds honey will
search for coupons um all over the
internet and then find the best one for
your site
if they find a working coupon you'll
watch the price drop immediately
so i've saved money on makeup on
clothing on
tech on literally anything anytime i'm
shopping on a website i'm like oh honey
probably doesn't know this random ass
website but then there they are they
just pop down and they're like
hey you want to save money oh click here
and it's just like little it's a little
gift like every every time you shop
yeah um when i when i shop at like
sephora or ulta i usually spend about
like 100
150 and they'll save me like 30 to 40
dollars like it's serious savings
serious savings if you don't already
have honey you could be missing out on
free savings
it's completely free to install and it
downloads in just a few seconds
by getting honey you'll be doing
yourself a solid and you'll be
supporting the toast if you use the link
joinhoney.com toast we recommend honey
we've been using it way before since
they were a sponsor
um so get honey for free at
joinhoney.com
toast that's joinhoney.com
toast love it okay fifth and final story
krispy kreme ceo is responding to
backlash
for offering a free donuts to vaccinated
customers
yeah this was um maybe not their best
idea no so i think was last week they
announced that
you if you go in and show your vaccine
card you'll get a free doughnut um
which just for a number of reasons like
doesn't make a ton of sense
yeah but i do appreciate the the
positive
yeah enthusiasm and encouraging people
to get vaccinated because it's so
important that we all know like the
intention was that it was so
pure krispy kreme is catching flack for
its latest promotion that offers a free
original glaze ooh they didn't say it
was original glaze
doughnut to any customer who shows their
cova vaccination card last monday the
chain announced that the author
offer is available at locations
nationwide however many social media
users called out krispy kreme in the
following days and pointed out that
obesity is a growing problem for
americans
and is a risk factor for coven 19
actually recent studies have shown that
it's actually
very much correlated to severe coded
cases
so um the ceo responded and said we're a
sweet treat company and a
sweet treat and if folks don't want to
visit a donut shop they don't have to
oh i kind of live for that respect like
his approach like like if you want a to
donate e1 if you don't go [ __ ] yourself
uh by the way i was not you know we live
in like we live in a time where
corporations are so conflict averse like
if there's a sniff
of controversy they literally release a
whole statement and donate a million
dollars to a charity
but the fact that this guy was like we
serve donuts like what the [ __ ] do you
want me to do we're just trying to help
like
i kind of live for that yes he further
pushed back against the criticism and
said
what's his name um his name is
tattersfield uh
mike tattersfield the ceo for boyfriend
cream
material wait for material he says that
if you look at what he looks like
he said that if folks want to get a
vaccine if they decide to combine a
krispy kreme pickup for a donut they can
that's how we look at it generosity no
that's the thing it's like at the end of
the day like
we are all adults like we make our own
decisions
no one's shoving a donut in your mouth
while you get the vaccine like it's not
mutually exclusive so like
okay yes optics wise it's like a little
silly be giving donuts but you know what
like
people are free to make their own
[ __ ] decisions and if i want to donut
i'm just going to go get one
100 i just need to see what this guy
looks like because if he's hot like
that's like seriously
game over for men no literally and
maverick okay images
oh no not maverick oh my god he's so so
cute oh my god he's like a pea john
nation
cutie oh my god you know who he looks
like and it's so ironic you remember
that episode of sex in the city where
miranda meets the guy at weight watchers
and then like they don't end up dating
because he's like so self-conscious
about like his body
he kind of reminds me of him yeah he's a
mad cutie
i drop off a lot of donuts to the
healthcare system they're very
appreciative given the days that they
have to work
people are always looking for a little
sweet treat break it's okay
also i just want to say um like living
for this response the crazy
same original glazed doughnut is worth
the calories i agree like of
all the sweet treats in the country like
it's a no-nonsense donut it's
top five probably the best dessert money
can buy
a hundred percent what else would i put
up there like really
like kind of savory desserts i would put
like a fresh krispy kreme like right out
of the oven
up there i personally would put um this
is just a personal favorite of mine
only a bakery i think i wouldn't but a
lot of people would parallel
i agree you know what else i would put
this is very niche i think maybe some of
our
fort lauderdale toasters will know what
i'm talking about the and this
restaurant hasn't been in business
in 15 years the tall house cookie pie
from beverly hills cafe in fort
lauderdale very niche
very random best dessert i've ever had
to this day i can literally taste it in
my mouth like
i'm so so familiar we used to eat there
all the time when we were kids
yeah is the beverly hills are are there
any locations of the beverly hills cafe
open because
i'm sure there are so many places called
the beverly hills i know but that was
like the best chain of restaurants
i think in my opinion in all of south
florida between the bread basket and
then the dessert
i dream of that place all the time i
also just have like so many fond
memories you know
of being like a family with two parents
like it was just like
i think like when i die like the you
know i feel like heaven is just like
a like a street with like all your
favorite places like i think the beverly
hills cafe
will be in stock members kevin and like
our whole family will be there like dad
like i think that
going ham on the bread basket and then
the tall house cookie pie like it's so
good so i'd put that up there
i would also put um this is also very
niche the
it's parv chocolate souffle from st hana
do you remember st hannah no
oh my god it's random kosher chinese
restaurant um
whatever back to krispy kreme i love
this man
and hopefully us praising them on the
podcast means tomorrow like a box of
donuts will arrive at our door because
that's the only reason i'm doing it
no i mean we're doing it because that's
how you feel you know i like i
bring it back to it just in case they
were like would these girls want krispy
kreme
yes i have a lot of respect for people
who like get backlash and like just kind
of like stick to their guns because like
it's like it's so hard i mean i get
backlash all the time and like i
always just like freak out and like you
know i like
just curl curl up in a ball
yeah but like you have to look inward
and you have to you have to ruminate on
it and say how do i feel about this
right
am i apologizing tatters field feels
good about giving donuts to people who
want donuts
right and like am i apologizing because
i'm sorry or because people want me to
be sorry and there's a huge difference
yes and the fact that he's like no no i
literally stand by this decision like
we're just trying to encourage people to
get vaccinated
it's not that deep um like one donut is
not gonna make you obese
i think that i really respect him and
mike tattersfield if you ever want to
come on the toast like
there's a seat for you and um sarah
tattersfield hopefully his daughter
who's a toaster
do tell your dad how much we appreciate
his response mike tattersfield said
it's not that deep mike that's the name
of today's episode i know it's like a
little long
but i think if we put mike
tattersfield's name in the podcast title
we'll have a better chance of getting a
krispy kreme delivery tomorrow
cause like he probably listens to
podcasts and like maybe scrolls down far
enough to see
we're garbage we're not far we're not
far no we're not
and if you guys all like even if you're
watching on youtube head over to the
podcast and read it
click play so that it like starts to so
imagine like the number one podcast in
the podcast store
mike tattersfield said it's not that
deep
and then i think that's like a surefire
way not only to get the free donuts
but to also get his unconditional life
and by the way
if we do get the free donuts we'll do a
mukbang on
patreon hundred percent that's a good
idea like with the asmr mics
oh i mean you just want to do that i
know anyway i've been meaning to do asmr
speaking of patreon i posted a late
night patreon video last night crazy
toast after dark um it was a cooking
video that i
filmed cooking on this lemon chicken
recipe from iron garden's cookbook that
i also made last night for my seder
and like the cooking process was like
super hectic and really chaotic i felt
like rachel right in there
and um people are really enjoying it
like claire crawley i literally did i
was like so stressed like just drinking
my way through it like it was really
crazy the only way to be um i gave you a
shout out and
i caught you in your lives yeah no i
haven't watched it yet because i was so
wrapped up in this book
but it's it's on my to-do list today
because i literally live for the vlogs
but i hate just watching it like
happens on my phone i want to enjoy it
on my bed
like in my pajamas i appreciate that
okay
and so if you want to enjoy it in that
way as well head over to patreon.com
morning toast premium content over 225
episodes that we've done that you get
access to if you sign up today
7.99 gets you five extra podcasts and
vlog episodes every month
from jackie and i we bring the steams in
we do it all
um and it's a great way to support the
show because the show is free it will
always be free
but you know the 7.99 cents is just one
coffee a month
um or one donut or actually i think it's
actually you can get a free doughnut and
then
yeah towards patreon um i want to talk
about real housewives of atlanta that
was on last night because
it i was literally about to text like
our group chat like that we always text
when we want to take a trip that we
should go to new orleans like for a
weekend sometime soon
because um drew did an amazing job like
they're having the best time it's really
such a nice
trip especially compared to the travesty
that was south carolina when there was
like
no food drew took it upon herself to
like plan a bomb ass trip
um and kenya's just like in a mood the
whole time
because she brought brooklyn and like
drew basically said anyone can bring
your kids and nobody did because like
they've been locked up with their kids
for a whole year like they want to get
out and go on a girls trip
but um kenya did and she's just like
kind of in a mood which i kind of
understand and i think the women like
especially when they just had flown and
then they're in the bus they get to the
hotel
and drew makes them do like a twerk off
for the best room and
kenya's like just give me the key i
don't care she takes like the worst room
she goes and upgrades herself she pays
for it herself
which honestly they were like i can
relate i that was the only thing you
know i'm not a kenya
defender i related to her so much it's
like really like give this woman a break
she has her kid with her and like she
just wants to get up to her room but
like
anyone after a long travel day it
doesn't want to do a
competition they flew private which um
so it wasn't like that treacherous but
just like with the kid like
she's [ __ ] tired like i totally
understand that i didn't think she was
being nasty about it all she was just
like done
she's like give me the key yeah um
but um latoya's like not drinking on
this whole trip because she acted like
an animal at fallon's house and i think
she's just like not trying to give the
women anything to talk about
but now what they're talking about is
the fact that she's not drinking so it's
just like
she can't win but like she did it to
herself she did it to herself and now
she's like in this impossible position
where she's just like fighting with
everyone she's like
in such like honestly the trip looks fun
but so many of the women are just in
perpetual bad moods like for the first
entire day marlo had thrown her back out
so she didn't show up to anything
toy is not drinking so she's in a bad
mood and then she's fighting with
everyone about not drinking
kenya's just like stressed with her baby
and just doesn't want to talk about it
drew is the only one who's like
literally having like the time of her
life because she has like all these work
opportunities
in new orleans like she goes to iheart
radio for an interview she had a meeting
with the production company
this is like the best trip of her life
and like so many of the women like
cannot be bothered to be there
porsha's actually having a great time
and cynthia's just like continues to be
the voice of reason
and i was really watching the episode
last night and i always feel like
cynthia is really the voice of reason
but she has a blind spot when it comes
to kenya like she doesn't see kenya
for who like kenya really is um
but i do think she's starting to get
annoyed with kenya that's just like a
feeling that i'm having
oh i have to catch up i didn't get a
chance to watch last night because i was
like really behind on my homework
yeah um but that sounds really great it
wasn't like a crazy dance
whenever i know so it wasn't a crazy
episode but it did make me want to take
a trip to new orleans like there's just
so many fun activities that basically
all revolve around drinking and i feel
like
we would have the best time well maybe
not you maybe not me but i think we
should go no
we can get cafe dumond like have you
been to new orleans no i've never
been i think i've been once twice or
once
but it's so fabulous and so fun and i
actually think you would really like it
okay i mean i'm in i mean like tell me
where we'll bring the podcast mics and
we'll just get to work you know and like
we can have like a whole like mardi gras
themed week like you know
oh yeah but we just missed mardi gras
for sure oh [ __ ] okay yeah we just have
like a whole bourbon street moment
okay premium content can't wait pink
gold and green like purple golden green
i think we should go um but yeah other
than that i literally did not watch any
tv this weekend because i was just so
wrapped up in being like a literary
queen
i love to see that i'm so happy for you
you made you
you logged into your own kindle account
i decided i officially
made the transition i made my own good
reads i made my own
like amazon kindle account so i
deactivated i lost all the books that we
had bought together but
i guess it's fine damn i just wanted my
own like thing
yeah now you have it and the only two
books i bought it's the one you got
good because it's one you got um um so i
only have two books in my store both of
the colleen hoover books but it's okay
i'll get there
yeah you you will do it and you're
enjoying
i am i mean it's just like ben wanted to
kill me last night because i didn't go
to bed till two because i was like
finishing reading this book and he just
like wanted to come in
the room and watch tv but i'm like sir
i'm so wrapped up
in atlas rile and lily's
story that i just can't really talk to
you i understand how would you pronounce
the name
r-y-l-e or isle
yeah riley no it's not riley it's rile
because
character yeah right okay it was weird
that was like the one thing i couldn't
really get on board with in the book
but it was fine because at least i was
reading it so i just like skimmed over
his name every time he came up i didn't
have to say
right but that's what's funny about the
redheads it's like when you talk about
the characters it's like oh how did you
wind up pronouncing that in your head
yeah ryle i think that's funny
um so yes that was called um it ends
with us and i just cannot recommend it
enough
it's one of my top five it was one of
the like the three books i've given a
top
five it's one of the three books i've
given five stars to up there with evelyn
hugo and lucky's girl live
wow that's an exclusive club no i know
like i really i give most of the books
that i read four stars because like
they're good but
when you change my life and i can't stop
thinking about you you guys think i have
to read it just to know why i don't want
to over hype it no
just to like understand what sort of
book you love like i like to read
someone's favorite book and be like oh
that's what you're into it says
about cause it was romance it was twist
it was thriller
and it had a little bit of erotica which
i was just not expecting from a book
that margot recommended to me
oh you'll find all of snitch's books are
because
all of like why a books are erotic yes
yes yes i didn't realize that's what the
kids are up to so the kids have gone
wild and i just really liked the book
and so many toasters like responded to
me that they like are obsessed with it
too
so um can't wait for the movie if it
ever comes out
um wow i'm so happy for you i will read
it i'm almost done with the transition
baby if you are also reading with us
make sure to email your questions
to the redheadsbookclub gmail.com i also
read so many other books this month so i
have so much to talk about like i
still i read da vinci code this month
still haven't wow it's been a long month
it's been a long month i've just been
like on such a
a reading kick i think my next book i'm
going to read is mary queen of scots
apparently we're just like on two
different planets two different planets
i'm on the plantagenet planet what's
that that's like the novels that are
like ambolyn
oh when i'm leaving you're on snitch
planet yeah no
i like snitch planet like hopeless
really okay hopeless was
when i was reading it i liked it but
afterwards i'm like why did i just read
that
it's finding carter okay you kept saying
that last night and i don't know what
that is binding harder was a show on mtv
that
i did watch and it was like on the time
when like faking oh my god yes
the girl don't spoil the book but yes
you guys
don't read it yes but if you know
finding carter she was
raised by a woman and then she got like
arrested one night with her friends and
it turns out that she actually had been
kidnapped when she was younger but the
woman who was raising her like she
thought was her mom and loved her
and so she gets like reunited with her
old family it's actually not exactly the
same but
it just was finding harder vibes oh my
god you kept saying that last night and
you're right i remember that show and i
it's literally just the premise of the
book yeah um
and you know there's also another
hopeless you've been missing for 13
years
you know there's also another hopeless
book in the series i think it's called
like
endless and it's his perspective no
no no no i'm so good i'm all set like i
really really am
um so yes that is our show
it's our show it's nobody else's mike
winklevoss whatever your name was um
reach out don't forget the donuts free
donuts and if you want to come on the
show don't forget
um and that's all she wrote correct it's
all she wrote she's done okay now i
can't say winklevoss not getting chill
down my spine because army hammer ruined
that too
i know but it's like imagine how the
wink of austrians feel oh
justice for the wiggle bosses actually a
lot of justice
for the winklevi because their idea was
stolen right yeah
and then they got played by the
disgraced queen himself
army hammer yeah i thought you could say
mark zuckerberg
no and and the movie like
made them enjoy the babies yeah yeah but
like it was their full idea
yeah and now that we watch like mark
zuckerberg steal everyone's idea we're
like oh wait maybe he literally did
steal that
no he did he stole that [ __ ] justice for
the winklevi like they were the og
creators
and by the way they didn't have as much
innovation as mark zuckerberg so like it
never would have turned into anything as
legitimate as facebook
but it's their [ __ ] idea yeah
and that's all she wrote thank you so
much for sending to the morning toast
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so let's
spotify itunes stitch or public radio i
have widow cat box all the places so
wherever you listen to the podcast find
us morning shows leave a five star
review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are
to all of our jewish toasters and we
hope you have an amazing holiday
see ya bye